well New York City police could share
new evidence today in the mysterious
deaths of two sisters from Saudi Arabia
CBS News has learned they may be ruled
suicides the body of 23 year old Ratana
and 16 year old Halle Ferrell were
discovered bound together last week
Jericka Duncan is next to the Hudson
River in New York where they were found
Jericka good morning good morning
investigators are trying to retrace the
movements of those sisters by using
credit card transactions and
surveillance video a source tells CBS
News that the sisters who came here from
Virginia to New York City got here in
September
another source tells us police are using
a phone number belonging to the sisters
to ping the whereabouts off local cell
towers now Ratana and Tala came from the
u.s. from Saudi Arabia with her mother
three years ago where they discovered
the last week bound together by duct
tape at the waist and ankles with their
hands-free now their bodies had no
obvious signs of trauma maybe suggesting
that perhaps they jumped off of a bridge
but investigators again it's been more
than a week they still do not have a
cause of death and say they are
interviewing friends and family of those
sisters down in Virginia Jon Jericka
thank you